Dann sollen die Hamburger den Antrag stellen, wir spielen ohne Ball. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Schwollo, außer bei dem Freistoß irgendwann noch mal den Ball gehabt hat in der zweiten Halbzeit. Und ich bin deshalb sauer, weil ich sage, wenn eine Mannschaft nicht im Rhythmus ist, dann einverstanden, 0-0, wieder Sicherheit, ein Punkt. Aber nicht, wenn du so gut gespielt hast – gegen Hoffenheim zahlen – und wirklich in einer Art und Weise gespielt hast, auch mit Angriffspressing, wie wir es analysiert haben, und dann hier so auftritt, dann ist das für mich einfach für die Bundesliga zu wenig. Und ich weiß, nochmals kann sich auch jeder aufregen. Ich respektiere das auch, aber das hat mit Fußball nichts zu tun.
Aber ist da nicht das Problem, dass die aktuell im Rentenalter befindliche Spielergeneration noch aus einer anderen Welt des Fußballs kommt? Denn wenn jemand Anfang der 2000er den Höhepunkt seiner Karriere hatte, der hatte damals noch nicht so viel mit Ernährungswissenschaft, Trainingsdiagnostik, Digitalisierung des Trainings- und Mannschaftsalltags zu tun. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen eine andere Welt.
Ja, aber der Unterschied liegt ja zwischen Aktionismus und Pragmatismus, sage ich immer. Das zu analysieren, wer das können soll, kann ja nur ein Fachmann. Und jetzt frage ich mich aber, wo neben Trainern die absoluten Sportfachleute sind. Und ich bin sogar noch ein bisschen bei ihnen. Manche sind auch zu faul. Aber es gibt auch wieder, ich finde Sebastian Kehl jetzt mit Borussia Dortmund genau richtig zu Akki Watzke und Michael Zorc jemanden dazu zu nehmen, der vor kurzem noch gespielt hat, die Belange, die Bedürfnisse, die Veränderungen mitbekommen, der Ansprechpartner ist und auf diese Stabilität des Clubs punktuell einwirken kann. Nur, die meisten Führungskräfte haben ja Angst, sich Qualität dazuzuholen, weil sie möglicherweise feststellen würden, da haben wir ja in der Vergangenheit oder wie auch immer. Und auch gesellschaftliche Themen wie Streitkultur, wie Ehrlichkeit, wie Vertrauen, wie Verlässlichkeit sind ja auch Bestandteile, mehr Qualität in einem Verein zu haben und damit umgehen zu können. Und deshalb, ich zähle es jetzt nicht auf. Aber gehen Sie doch mal in der Bundesliga durch, wo die Hauptverantwortlichen des Clubs die Kompetenz haben, dass sie mal ein guter Spieler oder ein guter Trainer werden. Aber sie sollen die Spieler beurteilen und die Trainer. Und ich rede nicht, dass es auch den ein oder anderen erfahrenen gibt. Und dass man als guter Trainer genauso eine blöde Diskussion nicht automatisch ein guter Spieler gewesen sein muss. Das ist völliger Blödsinn. Da gibt es auch genug Gegenbeispiele. Aber die Kompetenz muss gegeben sein und in großen Clubs auch nicht nur einseitig. Du musst auch eine Diskussionskultur haben, um die Stärke und damit das Fundament des Clubs zu stärken. Die Bundesliga hat nicht allein Qualitätsprobleme dadurch, dass die Spiele nicht attraktiv genug sind, sondern sie hat ein Thema dahingehend, dass sie sich zu viel hinter Themen versteckt, die mit dem eigentlichen Spiel und dem eigentlichen Leistungsprinzip des Fußballs nichts mehr zu tun haben, sondern Fehlervermeidung und Erklärungsversuche, warum das alles so logisch ist, dass es nicht gut funktioniert. Da sind wir mittlerweile schon Weltmeister.
Aber warum findet dann zum Beispiel so eine Sicht auf die deutschen Bundesliga so selten im Journalismus statt? Das wäre ja eigentlich die Aufgabe der Sportberichterstatter.
Nein, nein, das ist genau das, was ich sage. Wir können doch nicht den Journalisten dafür verantwortlich machen. Und bitte jetzt ganz viel Respekt. Die Journalisten sind Meinungsbilder in Deutschland. In der Regel kenne ich keinen Journalisten, der auf hohem Niveau Fußball gespielt hat, der mal Trainer war, der mal Sportdirektor war oder der einen Verein geführt hat. Und diese Leute sollen die Möglichkeit der Bewertung von Menschen, von Trainern, gehören zu den Menschen, von Vereinen, von Führungspersönlichkeiten fundamental, objektiv, dass das immer subjektiv ist, wissen wir, auch so ein klassisches Ergebnis, bewerten können. Für mich sind das Zauberer. Für mich sind das Zauberer. Es ist unmöglich. Es ist unmöglich. Das Problem ist nur, dass im dem Moment, wo du das ansprichst und die Leute ein bisschen damit konfrontierst, sofort die Haltung kommt, Unverschämtheit, das ist ja, was hat er denn geleistet oder was soll das? Nee, es ist die Wahrheit. Das, was ich nicht selber absolviert habe, aber aufgrund, ich sehe Fußball, Bundesliga, 30 Jahre, 40 Jahre, ach, das legitimiert mich, über Menschen zu urteilen in Personen, wo ich noch nicht mal weiß, wie sich das anfühlt. Ich sage, es sind Zauberer.
Es kann nicht die Aufgabe des Journalismus sein, weil die Substanz nicht vorhanden ist.
Sie wollen es. Sie wollen es gern und sehnen sich auch, wie der Journalist im Allgemeinen, als das Modul des gerechten und des ehrlichen und des richtigen – Die Wahrheit. Es ist nicht möglich. Und im Detail analysiert ist es ein Armutszeugnis. Sie sind jetzt auch ein bisschen auf der Seite. Ich will das gar nicht so sehr angreifen, aber Jan hat das entscheidend gesagt. Ich bin nur deshalb ein bisschen der Meinung, das muss schon noch aus dem Fußball kommen. Und die Berichterstattung ist eine Begleitersteinerung. Ich bin nur ein bisschen sauer, weil die Begleiterscheinung denkt, dass es der Fußball ist und das ist falsch.
Wir haben uns auch missverstanden, denn mir geht es nicht darum, dass die Journalisten jetzt uns die Wahrheit erklären sollen. Wie soll jemand wie ich, der nie Fußball professionell gespielt hat, ich werde nie alle Ebenen dieses Spiels verstehen. Es geht nicht. Ich könnte den Fußballlehrer ausbilden, aber warum werden solche Diskussionen nicht geführt? Wo ist die Streitkultur, die Sie auch im Bezug auf die Vereine angesprochen haben? Wenn ich das, was Sie sagen, auf eine Schlagzeile zusammenfasse, wie ich es überall lese, dann wäre das das Thema Stahlgeruch. Eine Entscheidung wie Hasan Salihamidzic oder Sebastian Kehl wird unter so einem Schlagwort beurteilt. Es gibt nicht einen, der sagt, es ist wichtig, eine Fußballkompetenz auf dieser Ebene mit dabei zu haben. Deswegen darfst du auch gerne noch die Gegenmeinung dazu geben von jemandem, der sagt, jetzt kommt wieder jemand, der vorher noch nie Management gemacht hat und soll Management machen. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, es fehlt diese Kontroverse, und zwar in der sachlichen Diskussion im Journalismus.
Auch das muss erst, genauso wie sich der Fußball gerade wieder weiterentwickelt, von außen beobachtet wurde, muss auch das erst wieder kommen. Und ich glaube, die Diskussion, sie wird kommen. Es ist natürlich dann wiederum die entscheidende Frage, wer führt die Diskussion? Ist dort Substanz dahinter oder ist keine Substanz dahinter? Das ist ja das Entscheidende. Es ist ja genauso bei der, ich kann auch einen ehemaligen Spieler holen, der diesen Stahlgeruch hat, wie auch immer das vom Geruch her ist. Nur, der hat nichts drauf. Das bringt mir auch nichts. Ich brauche einfach Leute, die die Substanz haben und davon gibt es nicht so viele. Es gibt nicht so viele. Ich kann ja jemanden holen, der auch ein ehemaliger Bundesligaspieler war, aber dem ist das wirtschaftlich hier viel wichtiger. Der sagt, für mich ist hier der Umsatz. Wir sind ein mittelständisches Unternehmen und die schwarze Zahn am Ende des Jahres ist wichtig, dass die mit mehr Erfolg vielleicht noch besser dann da wäre. Aber das ist erstmal das primäre Ziel. Also das ist die Besetzung der entscheidenden Posten in den Vereinen, wo die Struktur geschaffen wird. Das ist das Entscheidende. Und wenn dort Leute sind, Freddy Bobic, was hat der in kurzer Zeit in Frankfurt aufgebaut? Das hat der ja nicht alleine gemacht. Der hat ein Team zusammengestellt. Und was haben die für eine, in Anführungszeichen, komische Mannschaft? Also auf die Idee muss man ja erst mal kommen, so viele Nationen da zusammenzupacken. Aber dann hast du den richtigen Trainer dazu, der das inhaltlich und zwischenmenschlich und auch sprachlich regeln kann, weil als Trainer heute mit so vielen verschiedenen Spielern aus den verschiedensten Ländern ist natürlich nicht so schlecht, wenn ich wie Tedesco in Gelsenkirchen fünf Sprachen spreche. Und Nico kommt auch ganz gut klar mit verschiedenen Sprachen. Also darum geht es doch, dieses Team zusammenzustellen von Leuten, die platt gesagt einfach was drauf haben. Davon gibt es nicht so viele.
Und die Voraussetzung, den Fußball zu fühlen, ist nicht die Legitimation, in die Position zu kommen. Fußball, gespielt zu haben, Trainer gewesen zu sein, in eine verantwortliche Position zu gehen, bedeutet erst einmal Leerzeit. Also, aber das war für mich die Grundlage unseres Gesprächs, darüber nachzudenken. Also ein ehemaliger Spieler sofort in eine Führungsposition zu geben, das ist ja Kirre, darüber brauchen wir nicht reden. Aber ihn damit zu konfrontieren, als Verein an sich zu binden und dann die Zeit der Entwicklung in Verbindung zum Erlernen der Grundlagen zu geben, das ist für mich ein Modell, was sich richtig und logisch anfühlt, ist aber nicht das Einzige. Aber darüber sollte man schon mal nachdenken.
Letzte Frage, wir haben jetzt ganz lange über Fußball debattiert und wir könnten wahrscheinlich auch Stunden so weitermachen, aber ist es nicht vielleicht auch manchmal so, dass wir den Fußball zu ernst nehmen? Weil im Grunde sind wir doch eigentlich nur Teil einer großen Unterhaltungsindustrie. Hängt auch ganz viel Geld mit drin, aber um wirkliche Probleme geht es doch im Fußball selten.
Das ist klar. Also das sage ich auch immer, wir haben einen schönen Job, aber keinen wichtigen Job. Wenn wir einen Fehler machen, ja meine Güte, was passiert denn dann? Oder genauso die Fußballer auf dem Platz. Nur, es ist einfach traumhaft. Also es wird auch nicht langweilig. Und es ist ganz einfach, da ist was Rundes in der Mitte und da sind 11 auf der einen, 11 auf der anderen und die wollen das eine in das Netz und der andere in das Netz. Es macht einfach Spaß. Und es macht ja nicht nur wenigen Menschen Spaß, sondern unfassbar vielen. Und einfach diese Begeisterung. Es geht um Emotionen, die transportiert werden und das ist dann wiederum auch wichtig für die Leute. Also um nochmal wieder kurz etwas für Italien. In Italien ist im Moment eine Krise. Den Menschen, denen geht es dreckig, denen geht es schlecht. Arbeitslosenquote enorm hoch. Der Fußball hat dort im Moment auch in einer Stadt wie in Rom einen Stellenwert. Die Leute kommen morgens mit einem Lachen zur Arbeit, weil die Roma gegen Bas-Lohn-Arbeiter gekommen sind. Also es ist nicht zu unterschätzen. Und natürlich ist es eine Unterhaltungsindustrie, aber es ist einfach schön. Es sind Emotionen. Es ist etwas, was einen berührt und was mich mitnimmt und was auch Stimmungen verbessern kann. Also es ist nicht wichtig, wie ein Arzt, wie sonst irgendwas. Da muss man die Relation drin haben. Aber auf der anderen Seite hat das auf jeden Fall seine Berechtigung.
Fußball ist ein Bestandteil der Seele. Liebe, Emotionen, wenn man es denn mag, diese Richtung des Spiels und wenn man es gut findet, wie es andere Sportarten und andere Bereiche des Lebens gibt. Und das berührt die Menschen. Und deshalb ist es so faszinierend. Aber die Vergleiche anzustellen in Themen gesundheitlicher Art und Weise oder was Menschen darüber hinaus leisten können, um einer Gesellschaft zu dienen, der Vergleich hinkt. Weil wir in der Diskussion darüber, Jan hat es gesagt, eines der wichtigsten Bestandteile der Emotion, etwas ist, was uns als Menschen immer geprägt hat. Und die Leidensfähigkeit, die Freude, das ist ein Bestandteil des Lebens und deshalb ist es so wichtig. Und wer es für sich als unwichtig definiert, weil er das dabei nicht empfinden kann, dem gehört genauso unser Respekt.
Ach wunderbar, wenn ich mal wieder einen selbstkritischen Moment habe, ob ich mich wirklich auf den Fußball konzentriere, dann höre ich mir diese letzten fünf Minuten an. Matthias Sammer, Jan Henkel, vielen, vielen Dank, dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben.
Sehr gerne.
Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.